I was fully dreading coming to this
wedding until you showed
up could I get a cranberry juice with
ice and vodka when I first saw you I
thought that we should have sex in the
code
closet
yeah wait hold on I am kind of in a
weird place yeah you're in a beach club
coat closet you think that we could just
talk for a
minute romantic humiliations it's my
specialty I don't care the first person
to ever go down on me you're just going
to steamroll right on through I came in
my own
eye okay go
on I've had too many girlfriends over
the past couple years I can't figure it
out yeah we've all been there tell me
what I'll give you some of this pie if
you tell me more about your
tast
[Music]
it's not like I don't come with my own
complications we're engaged
oh wait you were
engaged it lasted 13 days you impressive
that is incredibly insulting but I see
what you mean will you welome into the
train station I actually have class no
you don't I like this J she's really hot
I know just wish I would have ended more
gracefully you ever see her
again this would never work you are
someone who cannot be counted on you've
run out on every guy you've ever been
with I'm a mess and I don't have any
answers but maybe you and I could figure
it out
[Applause]
together usually I feel so alone in my
memories but different with
you I'm happy to tell you a few more
embarrassing stories about my love life
well I promise not to laugh really I
promise not to laugh
[Music]
much